il a été élu le plus beau mec de France
parmi les 23 candidats sélectionnés
c'est Lenny
ça va tu étais content ouais franchement
c'était une belle aventure toi alors oui
non
il y a Daniel maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu fais quoi dans la nuit alors je suis
auto-entrepreneur oui d'accord donc je
travaille dans tout ce qui est sport
nutrition tout ça c'est ça ouais ça va
ça se passe bien franchement c'est cool
tu viens de quelle région alors moi je
viens de du coup du Sud je suis
originaire d'Avignon
la fierté de sa famille de ses proches
pour commencer quand tu arrives à une
soirée tu arrives toujours avec les
chars non non c'est vraiment pour les
événements il y a Mister France sinon
aussi
c'est pas la même que si tu dis il y a
rien
forcément pas forcément c'est comme
titre je reste toujours la même personne
mais c'est comme titre ah mais quand
même attends tu es content quand tu
arrives quelque part moi par exemple si
quelqu'un m'appelle au téléphone je dis
oui allô je suis Mister France si
j'étais toi toi tu dis tu le dis pas tu
le dis vraiment quand on te demande mais
pour le coup
si je dis je suis mes serpent sur
téléphone on rigole au nez
les personnes connaissent moins le
concours Mr France par rapport à la
version féminine et donc il y a pas
comme dans Miss France qui est repartent
avec des paniers de chocolats des
voitures
oui donc il y a des voitures il y a des
parures d'Europe il y a des parures de
bijoux en diamant il y a des
iPad ordinateur un appartement un
salaire pendant un an de voyage
et beaucoup beaucoup de et des voyages
combien de salaire
c'est comment le salaire de Miss France
et il y a pas encore les droits d'image
dedans parce qu'à la fin de l'année on
reçoit une grosse enveloppe pour tous
les droits d'images de ce qu'on a
l'année prochaine je me présente
et vous et moi je repars en train avec
ma valise
[Applaudissements]
pour des costumes des partenaires par
exemple je peux pas dire les marques
forcément mais des partenaires
sous-vêtements et j'ai pu faire des
voyages j'ai fait mon petit voyage en
Guadeloupe donc c'était vraiment pas mal
ouais alors François d'action vous êtes
quoi vous êtes le président du comité
Mister France je suis le président de la
marque Mr France que j'ai racheté en
2019 ah ouais et j'espère arriver à
lancer vraiment véritablement ce
concours qui a vraiment beaucoup de mal
à être visible dans les médias c'est
très très compliqué quoi
parce que comme on l'a dit Bernard tout
à l'heure ça manque certainement de
partenaires et puis il y a une
succession de propriétaires depuis 20
ans et ça n'a pas facilité l'ancrage de
la marque vous vous voulez vous voulez
vraiment faire un gros truc on est à
fond depuis 2019 et je vous remercie de
nous recevoir ce soir d'ailleurs ça nous
fait un peu de visibilité ça nous fait
plaisir aussi attendez alors il y a il
sait quand le prochain le samedi 4 mars
au Théâtre de Poissy d'accord on a 29
candidats alors justement on les a un
peu alors on va découvrir les les
profils des Mister France je dis ce que
vous en pensez il y a Mister Alsace euh
voilà qui
a une très belle choucroute
dans Mister Alsace voilà je trouve
il a l'air sympa alors voilà il sera
Alsace Mister Alsace il y a Mister
Auvergne
alors voilà alors
il y a Mister Bourgogne Franche-Comté ah
oui pas mal ténébreux ténébreux on
dirait ton film
en fait c'est un milieu je pense ou en
fait il y a une inégalité entre les
hommes et les femmes
sont beaucoup mieux payés que les hommes
on peut le déplorer bien sûr mais là
dans les concours de beauté ben force
c'est de constater que quand on a Diane
vous êtes absolument charmant mais Diane
l'air on est passionné il me dit ah on
est passionné et les hommes c'est super
dur pour vous je trouve alors que vous
l'avez vu sur l'essence
est constater que je trouve que c'est
super dur pour vous et alors pourquoi
vous prenez pas complètement un autre
contre-pied au lieu d'avoir la même
esthétique que le les missions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
absolument cyril a raison
un truc beaucoup plus moderne beaucoup
plus mannequin enfin je trouve que c'est
pardon pardonnez moi vous êtes ils sont
tous beaux charmant de ça mais c'est
ringard enfin moi je trouve que c'est
méga par rapport à ça
dans ce concours de Mister France c'est
pas forcément la beauté parce que chacun
a une définition propre de la beauté
maintenant c'est ça exactement sauf que
maintenant ce que nous on prend ce
concours de beauté parce que forcément
il faut le caractériser bien sûr c'est
que en charge des personnes qui ont de
l'ambition des personnes qui ont envie
de faire changer les choses des jeunes
qui ont envie de montrer
aujourd'hui moi ok j'ai tablette de
chocolat mais à côté de ça mais j'ai
écrit un livre par rapport à mon passé
par rapport à ce que je peux comment je
peux aider les personnes justement
de tous les côtés en fait le concours a
été aussi voilà il a il a été un petit
peu secoué parce que voilà il disait que
voilà il sait c'est un truc qui serait
jamais pour les femmes mais il disait
ouais le les mecs ils sont pas ouf alors
regardons alors on va on va revoir les
candidats on a Mister Bretagne voilà
voilà qui est trop cuit il est là
et lui continue
de belles photos
[Applaudissements]
vous faites une blague
c'est
modernement
Mister Guadeloupe
voilà Mister Île-de-France je pense
qu'il vous faut voilà
Mister Languedoc il est beau ah ouais on
va voir les autres
là où Géraldine a raison c'était dans la
présentation qui est une présentation un
peu archaïque un peu à l'ancienne qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui des pompiers mais
oui aujourd'hui
non mais vous le j'ai envie de dire que
en fait vous le calquez sur l'archétype
de ce qu'on avait avant chez les Miss
France qui elles ont évolué déjà donc
c'est ça qu'on peut être fait que vous
passez et qu'on a on aurait envie
d'avoir des garçons qui sont dans la
vraie vie c'est-à-dire plus moderne plus
François François qu'est-ce que vous
dites aux gens qui qui ont critiqué
voilà parce qu'ils ont critiqué un peu
il y en a même un qui a dit c'est pas
Mister France c'est Mister Freeze
on a on a 4 ou 5000 candidats qui
s'inscrivent chaque année sur le site
internet c'est départager par région et
dans chaque région on sélectionne celui
qui correspond le plus pour être
sélectionné il faut avoir entre 18 et 30
ans mesurer au moins un mètre 78
nous on cherche l'idéal masculin mais
c'est très compliqué quoi
[Rires]
Delphine alors moi
j'étais de Mister universel France la
semaine dernière c'est un peu votre
concurrent parce que c'est quand même
alors
[Rires]
on fait ça on est morte je peux vous
dire je peux vous dire il y en a il y en
a des effectivement des très beaux mais
les critères sont différents parce que
chez eux ça commence à partir d'un mètre
73 je pense que votre critère de 1m78
c'est trop c'est trop grand parce qu'en
fait il y a plein de super beau mecs qui
sont aux alentours de 1,75 c'est ça le
problème mais bien sûr que si tu
comprends
l'année prochaine c'est un mètre 50
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi je vous invite à venir le 4 mars
aussi je pense que parce que les hommes
deviennent beaux quand ils mûrissent
voilà et donc je pense qu'il faudrait ça
c'est parce que vous aimez les jeux de
murs
je pense que quand ils sont trop jeunes
c'est pour ça qu'on arrive pas trop à
s'identifier une jeune fille c'est
différent qu'un jeune garçon je pense
que vous devriez les prendre et ensuite
pour vous expliquer à toutes les
personnes qui n'ont jamais été là-bas
l'émotion qu'il y a dans les concours
masculins dans les concours masculins
c'est vraiment très beau parce que vous
êtes tous hyper passionné
[Applaudissements]
il y a une très belle ambiance et vous
êtes tous très ému et on sent que le
concours masculin a envie de a envie de
prendre n'empêche que pour revenir de
façon un peu sérieuse blague à part on
se marrait comme ça sur un concours de
femme
exactement
donc pourquoi on peut se marrer sur des
garçons
vous avez l'air un peu en colère je vois
votre visage fermé renfrogné là quand on
voit vos quand on voit vos critères il
faut être célibataire etc etc
respectueusement pourquoi vous changez
pas tout parce que je trouve que c'est
un peu ringard et tu veux qu'il demande
quoi alors
célibataire
ne change pas tout François
le Mister France après comme Lenny et je
n'ai jamais chez lui le week-end s'il a
une femme et des gamins
cette année donc nous on peut on peut se
caler là-dessus
vous l'avez vu est-ce que vous avez vu
une grosse une vieille vous avez vu
les mêmes le même plateau même plus le
même plateau
vous voulez vous voulez aller pourquoi
c'est la grosse soirée phare de TF1
pourquoi c'est la grosse soirée de phare
de TF1 avec Jean-Pierre Foucault
pourquoi
d'une association c'est avec mes données
personnelles que je porte à bout de
brasse camp et pourquoi aucun diffuseur
ne serait intéressé à ce moment là par
contre pour l'instant je n'ai personne
qui veut produire il y a pas un petit
garçon qui en France
à l'âge du concours nous sommes ça fait
20 ans que nous sommes présents sur
propriétaire
là c'est une des premières infos ont été
invité sur une heure de rendez-vous il y
a 2 ans avec Bilal que Cyril la
gentillesse de recevoir et qui très
compliqué pour venir
visibilité
si Mister France c'est bien produit et
tout mais bien sûr que ça marche bien
la vérité je te jure que Mister France
je suis persuadérée
de voir des beaux garçons évidemment
est-ce que vous pensez que moi je veux
faire ça
franchement vous le prenez sur C8
honnêtement moi si j'étais pas trop de
la chaîne
non pas du tout mais franchement mais
j'aurais proposé
il faut vous dire la vérité pourquoi
est-ce que ça j'aurais demain de 5 fois
parce que ça marche bien honnêtement je
sens ils sont dans la langue ils sont
très beaux mais je vous dis franchement
moi ça m'intéresse pas du tout
ça m'intéresse mais ce matin
là Mister France et bah franchement j'ai
pas envie de voir Mr France ouais
je suis très beau gosse Mister
Martinique ils sont en train de le
retrouver
ils sont partis en Martinique le
chercher
Mister Méditerranée
il y a Mister Midi toulousain
regardez voilà et après il y a Mister
Mister Nouvelle-Calédonie très beau très
beau
[Rires]